now this works technically but there's a
problem what if we have a dozen types of
entities that we might need to spawn or
50 or even 100 realtime strategy games
for instance contain many different
entity definitions riding out a spawn
entity function to represent all of
these items would involve a large case
statement that wouldn't really scale
well for programmer maintenance over
time
for instance if a designer wanted to add
a new type of entity they'd actually
need a programmers help to do it
to go in and add a specific line of code
for that entity type the problem is
further visible if you consider code
maintenance adding references to class
definitions throughout your code base is
just asking for problems to address this
issue we're going to take advantage of
an interesting property in JavaScript
namely that we can create a new object
given a handle to its definition to
allow this each overloaded entity
definition will update a hash table with
a pointer to its class definition once
we have a hash table entry between the
string name of the instance class we can
then use this instance to create a new
version of that class remember that in
grits map development is done through a
program called tiled which allows our
content creators to place objects in the
world and set their type via a string
this means that the data that we'll be
receiving from our map definition file
is a list of objects with a string
property representing their class type
our code needs to be able to react to
this by using the hash table that map's
these string values to the class
definitions they represent what this
means is this previous definition of
spawn entity function needs to be
replaced with a nice healthy reference
to this Factory object and use it as
we've defined